Selbstbestätigung als starkes Land sogar
also fang nicht ein, sondern zerstöre unsere
er wird mit dem Land einverstanden sein
uns so stark zu sehen, wie wir sind
wir können es einfach dorthin bringen und dort zerstören
ein paar Dörfer in wenigen Minuten
[Musik]
Ich bin seit dem 14. Jahr ehrenamtlich tätig
An der Front habe ich die Drohnen des Besitzers verwendet
Pause zwischen dem 15. Lebensjahr und
Im 22. Jahr wurde es nicht gefüllt, wenn
unser Land ist voller Ruhe
sehr schön und mit Drohnen zu fotografieren ist toll
schön kannst du
Es ist ein solches Hobby wie Aerofotografie möglich
zu sagen, ich bin dort auch sein Unterstützer
Es stellte sich heraus, dass meine Dienste außergewöhnlich sind
gefragt von der Armee Nun, zum Glück in
Prinzipien Wir entschieden viele, viele
Aufgaben mit Hilfe dieser Drohnen werden wir
lösen
Gewisse Kenntnisse auf diesem Gebiet habe ich aber trotzdem
Ich habe es, und ich habe es ein bisschen gemacht, das ist alles
Dinge in der Anlage haben mich sehr zurückgebracht
schnelle Intelligenz buchstäblich in der ersten
Während des Krieges habe ich alles zusammengetragen, was ich hatte
Ich habe mich vorbereitet, ich verstehe, dass Krieg das kann
beginnen
Jetzt basiert alles Leben auf einer Armee
Drohnen sind erstens die Augen des Krieges, zweitens -
es ist immer noch eine Schockkomponente
Zunächst einmal ist es die Erkennung des Feindes
da musst du mal schauen was da passiert
Seite, um zu wissen, welche eigentlich
Maßnahmen, die wir ergreifen sollten, um Artillerie abzufeuern
wie Sie Ihre Positionen zurückziehen
voraus und so weiter
Intelligenz entschied realistisch und
humanitäre Aufgaben ist, dass wir
zum Beispiel wussten sie nicht, was mit ihnen los war
von unseren Flüchtlingen auf dieser Seite dh
es gab tatsächlich einen Menschenfreund
Der Korridor entlang dieser Böschung ist anders
humanitärer Korridor da drüben auf dieser Brücke
auf dieser Böschung
Wir haben herausgefunden, dass es dort ein Problem gibt
das Wasser ist gestiegen und sie können nicht einfach
Sie haben dort einen normalen Übergang gemacht
ein improvisiertes Floß, auf dem Sie können
zum Beispiel eine liegende Person zu überqueren
oder alle anderen müssen so gehen
Wasser und dann gab es eine Temperatur
die Wassertemperatur liegt irgendwo zwischen 3-4,5
Was ist, wenn nicht jeder es kann und das war es eigentlich?
deswegen war er sich sozusagen sicher
ein solches problem mit würzen, wir würden wenn
Natürlich ist der Hersteller durch Vermittlung dabei
Das Rote Kreuz wurde hier ohne Erkältung gefunden
so ein kleines Boot wiegt 70 kg und
er warf nur, dass sie es könnten
von Wir irgendwie so wenig zu überqueren
zivilisiert zumindest diesen Prozess
soweit sozialisierbar
alle Situationen
[Musik]
Wir haben auch verschiedene Informationen über
etwas zerstört in wem, das heißt, gut
elementare Menschen Vielleicht gibt es wissen
möchte mal wissen in welchem ​​zustand
ihr Haus
Es gibt verschiedene Arten von Drohnen, die komplex sind
Management ist einfach, das heißt, für einige
einfache Drohnen im Prinzip auf meiner
Überzeugung ist einfach vorsichtig
und ein ausgeglichener Operator, der kann
schon bestimmte Aufgaben zu lösen sein
vorne sehr praktisch
Es ist Teil unseres Jobs, was Sie tun
Wenn Sie eine zivile Drohne verwenden, müssen Sie
es ist nur zu akzeptieren, davor zu sein
bereit, dass Sie da erschossen werden
Zylinder A ist aus der Sicht sichtbar
den Betreiber zu finden, und er wäre weit davon entfernt
fliegt Das heißt, Sie sind die ganze Zeit Ot gezwungen
den Feind beißen und diese wenigen
sogar Hunderte von Metern um
Sie waren ein paar Meter weiter und starben
wo es dich interessiert
vor
Mörserbeschuss
Cannon Optim ist Teil des Jobs
des jetzigen Betreibers, das hoffe ich aber
nach einem Monat ändert es sich irgendwie Wir
Wir werden genug Drohnen bekommen
militärischer Standart
Militärstraßen Das ist natürlich eine andere Geschichte
Sie können von weit her einfliegen
unmerklich für den Feind außer mir
Militärdrohnen sind immer noch persönlich hier
Ich habe meine Hände seit eineinhalb Monaten Krieg nicht gesehen
hielt nicht
[Musik]
für mich würde ein sieg bedeuten
Entmilitarisierung Russlands
das heißt, damit es keinen wirklichen Feind gibt
kann uns
es wird ein Sieg sein, das heißt, ich verstehe, was sie sind
theoretisch können wir das erreichen
sogar die Ukraine verlassen
aber Russlands Traum von dem, was nicht bleiben wird
wir werden niemals vernichtet, deshalb denke ich das
es wird notwendig sein, eine solche Parität zu erreichen
Militärische Möglichkeiten Wann es sein wird
garantiert
[Musik]
wenn Sie der Ukraine helfen wollen
Bitte senden Sie Siege in die Ukraine
militärische Drohnen oder Hilfe
Geld durch Wohltätigkeitsfonds und so
Glory to Ukraine wird uns wirklich helfen